commençons notre descente et allons
traverser une petite zone de turbulence
bientôt à la maison
bien sûr que ça va ça recommence tu me
causer de sérieux dégâts sur les maisons
situées tout le long
il faut boucler la file un orage
cataclysmique est sur le point de
s'abattre sur manhattan
regardez il ya des requins à manhattan
maintenant les vols sont au match
décevant
c'est vrai que c sera franchie 300
l'année il sera le premier touché il ya
des requins au volant
des inondations importantes voire
couleurs madame dévastation monstrueuse
et sans précédent comment nous allons
jeter la banque je dois trouver une
tronçonneuse
celle que vous avez peur j'ai peur
personne ne me sur des braises ouais c
était et pour 2 fut là parce qu'il en
faut plus pour mettre un homme à terre
et encore plus pour mettre à new york
est à terre lorsqu'un malheur nous fera
pour anton coup pour coup faut faire
vite avant que les vortex notre joie
des requins